okay Wow I like kind of nervous this is
crazy can you see what's inside this
circle if not don't worry neither can I
chances are you're probably color blind
just like me the only time my color
blindness is really an issue is what I'm
editing and I have to do color
correction so are you are you color
correcting Rekha yeah
does it look red at all to you there's
the occasional moment where I may have
gotten something confused
I wear this color I don't wear this
color they're the same color
I've been colored white my entire life I
didn't really think that I was missing
out on anything I can still see color I
just don't see color the same as
everybody else
about a year and a half ago I heard
about this company called Inc Roma that
makes these glasses that are supposed to
help colorblind people see color I saw
these videos that kept coming out of
people trying the glasses and having
these big emotional experiences like
they were seeing something amazing for
the very first time and with all this
excitement I realized I had to at least
try these glasses so I grabbed Becky and
we headed up to Berkeley California to
tour the company and of course try out
the glasses I have a company and we were
making laser safety eyewear and one of
the features of these eyewear was that
it greatly enhanced colors just serve a
side effect the surgeons loved it so
much they were stealing there so I
started wearing him as like all these
work great I'm an avid Ultimate Frisbee
player and I was at a tournament in
Santa Cruz California at the turn of my
friend borrowed the glasses and he said
quote dude these are awesome I can see
the cones turned I he was color blind
and he couldn't differentiate the
fluorescent orange field marker cones
from the grass the orange cones yes yes
or the same to him until he put the
glasses on then he could see these the
ko
clearly well the lenses that I had made
absorb when a laser functioned
eventually we figured out it was because
they were creating separation between
the photo pigments I read everything I
could on the subject most prevalent form
of this red-green color blindness which
is what 90 some percent of everybody has
who's colorblind is called red green and
that's hereditary males have like a
50/50 chance I fell into that 50%
because my grandfather was colorblind
and passed that trade down to my mother
who then gave it to me
in fact my grandfather actually found a
way to cheat the colorblind test to get
into the Navy what exactly is it that's
happening inside somebody's eye that
makes them color blind to really
understand you have to understand how
normal color vision works because you
have three photo pigments you can call
them blue green and red the red and the
green one actually are right next to
each other the normal color vision the
red and green sensitive photo pigments
have some overlap in the abnormal form
for colorblindness they overlap too much
the more they overlap the more severe it
gets one of the glasses due to someone
like me that's you know red-green
deficient is that kind of separate them
more so you could see the difference
between the red and the green if you cut
out wavelengths that correspond to where
there's too much overlap you recreate a
separation you reestablished normal
capture of photons and now all those
mechanisms that are in here start to
function it's like oh that's clearly
different now the question is can you
can use are you seeing a difference are
you actually seeing red and green
we were driving past this thing and I
had to check it out over here we go this
is the first time he putting on the
glasses he look like some cool like
ray-ban Wayfarers I'm into that
I'm like kind of nervous this is crazy
whoa whoa this dress
it looks so blue that's green and pink I
couldn't see that green before I thought
it was brave Wow okay let's keep moving
let's go let's see what's next the trees
and then the grass on the hill and then
the red and then the brown and then the
green and then the blue there's so many
colors oh my gosh this has multiple
shades of green in it it's like being on
an acid trip from what I've heard
I can't believe that this is what
everybody else gets to see on a regular
basis to see this to see why people cry
at sunset sometimes I I don't I don't
know if I've ever seen anything this
beautiful